Now we're going to apply these
pyramids to Lucas and Kanade.
So here's another really, really ugly
picture and what I'm going to do is
I'm going to step you through
the algorithm in a minute, but
let me just show you sort of in,
in drawing.
Okay?
So first is here's our image at t
minus one, here's our image at t.
We reduce and we reduce on both of these
in order to get small versions of them.
The first thing we do is this
M stands for motion model,
we run Lucas and
Kanade between those two.
Okay?
And that gives us a flow field, okay?
And what we do is we make and
that tells you how every pixel moves,
we double up and multiply it by two that
flow field and then we apply that to
the next level down and then there's
this funny function called warp.
We take that function,
we warp the level one of t minus one and
now that's almost a level one at time t.
It's almost there.
So, you know what we can do
because it's almost there?
We can run Lucas and Kanade again.
All right?
We come up with a new motion field,
add it back to the motion
field that we had before.
Expand that, multiply by two,
apply in warp and continue.
And that's how the iterative Lucas and
Kanade algorithm works.
I know that that's hard
to see from a picture.
Here is the algorithm
written out as steps.
So we're going to compute to level K,
right?
So we build all of our
Gaussian up to level K.
We initialize the flow field as
being 0 at sort of K plus 1,
then what do we have to do?
Well, you know, here we're
doing it from level K to zero.
So from the previous level, we have
the flow field from the previous level,
which of course is half the size.
So we have to upsample the flow field,
that's just expand it,
make it twice as big.
All right?
And that's now the right size to
map from level K to level K of
t minus 1 to t.
The problem is if in the previous
level something moved
by 1.2 pixels,
how far is it going to move now?
1.2 times 2, 2.4 pixels.
So when I expand the flow field,
which is makes it a bigger size.
I also have to multiply it by 2.
That's what the next step
of the algorithm is just,
is multiply uip,
vip by 2 to get the predicted flow.
And then you warp that level
of the Gaussian of image two
towards image one in order to
get 2 prime or t minus 1 to t.
Whether you call it one or
two, it doesn't matter.
And you just keep iterating and
then we apply Lucas and
Kanade again between the warped version.
And that same level at of I1 to get
this slight what's called the correction
flow and we have to add that correction
flow back to the expanded flow that we
had before that's what these,
these equations here are doing.
They a, they are adding that slight
difference that we now found back to
the original predicted flow.
Here are some results, so this is
an example of that optic flow and
here is that tree.
And you can see if we don't
do it hierarchically,
we just apply Lucas-Kanade,
it does a nice job on the background.
But up on the tree itself, where
there was a large amount of motion,
it gives you exactly what you'd expect,
which is junk.
But when we run it with the pyramids,
we get a better solution and so you get
these nice, you know, flow fields
here in the middle, also in the back.
Now you'll notice we still have
a problem at the boundaries, all right?
And why is that?
Well, remember at the boundaries,
there are pixels appearing and
disappearing and there's no way that
optic flow knows what to do when a pixel
appears out of nowhere.
Basically, because you moved and
now there are pixels that were
invisible before are now visible.
And so the the optic flow along
the occlusion boundaries is
still a problem and you need
further processing to handle that.